I had a chief of staff who I was lucky to
work with for a year named Kimberly Cotton,
and she was the chief of staff to the
CEO of this Fortune 500 company. I met
her backstage speaking at a large event for
that company. Turns out her CEO was retiring.
Anyway, to make a long story short,
she was a master question asker,
and she illuminated for me something that I
had experienced over my life, which is there
are three types of questions that you can ask
someone that really actually make a difference,
that help shape or edit the future in some
way. And so, in this video, I’m going to
give you what I believe are three way better
conversation starters that maybe could replace
all icebreakers. And I’m going to get really
close and intense to share these three framings.
At one level, you can ask possibility questions,
right? What is possible? Sharing a vision for what
is possible in the future. On the next
level, you ask process questions. It’s
a little bit more digging into the how—how
do you actually wind up there? And then Kim
was amazing at asking practical questions. So I
would share this vision or an idea for something,
and she was a master of saying, “That’s amazing.
By when would you like to have that done?”
So let me give you three questions that I
really love that you can walk someone through,
right from possibility into process
into a very practical place. You ready?
At the possibility level of questions,
you’re really talking about vision,
right? Getting someone’s larger aim. It doesn’t
need to be hyper-specific. You’re just like, “What
do you want?” Right? Those kinds of questions. If
I ask you a question like, “If you could solve one
problem in the world, what would it be?” And
so when I hear somebody’s response to that,
what I’m now getting curious about—if I’m
kind of hovering—I almost picture these
possibility, process, and practical levels
like a spiral, where you’ve got to start
in the land of possibility, in the land of
why, what’s the point, what’s the big vision.
Otherwise, what happens too often is
when we try to get action-oriented,
we ask practical questions. Practical questions
are great at generating a bunch of activity that
leads to nowhere because they’re not tied to
some larger vision. And so, when you start with
the level of possibility and you spiral down
to how it’s going to get done—process—when I
ask you a question like, “What brings you joy?”
and then I’m able to combine that with, “Okay,
you want to solve this problem, and what brings
you joy?” I can now start to think, how do those
intersect? How might you combine those? So there’s
some reflection and debriefing happening there.
And then, really practically, what is it that you
want to start doing? So you can see
this is just three question examples.
I got so on about this idea that questions
are the edit button to the future, that
questions that are future-focused spark
the tiny actions, which is us verbalizing,
us creating new neural pathways that lead to
actual implementation out in the world. And so
what I did was spend a whole heap of time packing
60 possibility, process, and practical questions
into what I believe is the coolest tool to replace
all other icebreakers or conversation starters.
It is the Future-Focused We
Connect Cards, and it’s really
simply a deck designed to help people talk their
way into a more compelling, interesting tomorrow.
The no-prep takeaway here is that when you’re
in a group, if you can start with possibility
questions as a conversation starter, and then take
their answers to that and add a process-oriented
question like, “How do you like going about that?”
and then drop it into really practical terms like,
“What’s the tiniest action you might want to
take in the next week to make that happen?”—that
sequence of possibility to process to
practical is transformative for a group.
And so, if you want to start conversations that
actually go somewhere, that make a difference,
that is your formula. If you want to pick up a
deck of these cards, they’re available on the
internet. I guess they’re sponsoring this
video. I don’t know. Have an awesome day.